The Secret Service is more than black
sunglasses earpieces and two-piece suits
they're also an elite team of
investigators solving some of the
nation's biggest crimes sometimes using
nothing more than a blot of ink here we
are the lobby of the Secret Service
these were the only authorized shots we
could get upstairs in the lab we got to
see all the high-tech machines analysts
use in forensic investigations they have
names with things like 8,000 after them
so you know they're complicated did you
film a printer I did the lab includes
people like Trista who specializes in
handwriting analysis to investigate
threat letters or ransom notes
Jeffrey investigates fraudulent items
like IDs traveler's checks credit cards
and Irina she works in the International
Inc library my name is Irina Guymon I am
a document analyst with the United
States Secret Service the Secret Service
has the largest ink library in the world
there are over 12,000 inks they're
currently in a collection this includes
pens bottled ink and printer cartridges
basically this team of scientists is
using ink to help solve crimes their ink
vestigators no don't do that
okay so here's an example someone writes
a threatening letter to the president
Irina will sample that ink and then
compare it to her collection exactly she
can figure out what kind of ink was used
and hopefully it helps us solve the case
here's another ink sample no give me
that script the most counterfeited
banknotes within the United States is
$20 and it's printed with a Chuck which
means somebody takes they're very simple
at home printer and decides to print
money Irina can compare the counterfeit
currency to any printers found at the
scene of the crime and help make a match
okay time for a little science here's
what you need 12,000 samples of let's be
honest mostly black ink a lot of the
black inks and I just block they're
actually a collection of different color
components that could be a blues and
reds and yellows maybe a little bit of
green Irena Ken for lack of a better
term sequins black ink liquid DNA and
find the exact breakdown of color that's
how she can make a match
so what appear is black at a first
glance is actually extremely different
on the inside and it's really fun as a
chemist to be able to take the ink apart
and see how it's made
I'm a nerd at heart I love the chemistry
oven I love the mystery of salivating
case I just really love what I do so it
may not look exactly like it's on TV but
it's really fun to be in a lab and to be
able to do any analysis and to be able
to help and assist all the
law-enforcement agencies that I work
with daily so Irina can you give us any
more examples it's on a need-to-know
basis and you did not need to know well
it looks like this case she's all dried
up
you